okay here we are having lunch so i'm  gonna get up and take a bit of a video  of the uh the lunchroom absolutely  delicious lunch delicious soup  and uh chicken and stuff and i'm gonna  switch this  around there's this absolutely  passionate discussion going on  we have benson here we have got a  delegation from france actually benson  and we have  adam from golden we have richard from  fresh christine from  but i tell you i i have to say i was  most fascinated by the quality of the  korean  from the french delegation so  [Applause]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  i'll pay you  [Music]  [Laughter]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  um  okay we'll close it there thank you very  much friends and this is only a small  sampling of the kind of people that are  attending this conference just hold me  away  [Music]  you